bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par Monsieur
tatalic pour le groupe
GDR Marou Marou madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mesdames
messieur les ministres chers
cèg ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outr
depuis plusieurs moi et encore cette
semaine vous avez reçu les maires des
Hana des îles Marquises ils souhaitent
la création d'une communauté d'archipel
des îles Marquises espérant des
compétences élargies et surtout des
financements plus importants dans
certaines interventions il est même
question de créer une autre collectivité
polynésienne qui pour nous est synonyme
de partition de la Polynésie monsieur le
ministre
de nous sommes un seul peuple et un seul
pays une partie i serait un désastre
culturel et social et un nonsens face à
l'Histoire comme kanaki
Nouvelle-Calédonie la Polynésie est
engagée dans un processus de
décolonisation et d'émancipation notre
pays doit rester uni et la France n'a
plus à décider des frontières d'autres
pays à l'autre bout du globe nous
demandons la position officielle du
Gouvernement sur ce sujet nous entendons
et comprenons l'appel des archipels
polynésiens la nouvelle majorité
indépendantiste dont est issu le
président MU broderson est favorable à
une évolution statutaire pour plus de
décentralisation vers les archipels
également l'app l'application
indifférencié du Code Général des
collectivité territoriale inadapté à nos
réalités doit nous inquiéter nous
souhaitons monsieur le ministre revenir
un code des communes polynésien voté par
l'Assemblée de Polynésie repenser les
communes leur donner une fiscalité
propre augmenter les financements mieux
répartir les compétences entre l'État le
pays les archipeles et les communes pour
cela monsieur le ministre envisagez-vous
l'ouverture d'un dialogue sur la
réécriture du code des communes
polynésiens
Mar merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Philippe viget
ministre en charge des outres mes merci
madame la présidente madame messieurs
les députés monsieur le député é matille
leayic je sais votre attachement à ce
sujet institutionnel mais je vous
répondre sans
détour vous étiez présents le 20 octobre
dernier en présence de la première
ministre autour du président de la
République avec l'ensemble des
parleement des territoires ultramarins
avec l'ensemble des présidents de
collectivité et des présidents
d'association des maires le président a
dit une chose très simple il n'y a pas
de tabou sur les évolutions
institutionnelles mais ne comptez pas ni
sur la première ministre le président ni
sur les ministres pour écrire à votre
place l'avenir de ces territoirees ça
veut dire quoi il y a deux personnalités
qualifiés qui vont être choisies dans
les prochains jours par le Président de
la République qui rencontreront tous les
acteurs et on verra quelle est la
demande quelles sont les demandes des
uns et des autres pour des évolutions
institutionnelles parce que je rappelle
comme vous êtes parlementaire que si un
jour il y a une évolution
institutionnelle à un moment ou à un
autre il faudra simplement une réunion
du Congrès à Versailles donc il faut
d'abord un qu' a un accord local de qui
on a la capacité demain à porter une
réforme dans laquelle on se retrouve moi
les parlementaires se retrouve largement
une majorité de 3/5e et sachez bien que
notre volonté c'est pas de démanteler
les territoires de la République c'est
d'apporter plus de souplesse plus de
compétitivité plus d'attractivité bref
de simplifier les relations entre l'État
et les collectivités je profite de cette
question pour vous dire aussi que la
polie n'est pas oubliée je vous rappelle
qu'il y a un statut de fonctionnaire qui
a été enfin donné aux agents polynésien
et Sébastien Lecornu qui est là le C
parce qu'il a été en charge de ce
ministère avant moi je rappelle qu'il
des dotations par habitant au moment où
c'est la semaine du Congrès des Maires
et vous savez très bien que la Polynésie
n'est pas du tout oubliée puisque la
dotation par habitant aessus de la DGF
est 30 % audessus des communes de
l'Hexagone comptez sur nous pour
toujours aider la Polynésie merci
beaucoup monsieur ministre monsieur le
député Mar monsieur le ministre ce
n'était pas la question la question
c'était sur le code des communes
polynésiens plutôt que la CGCT et sur
les Marquises il faut être clair on ne
veut pas avoir des command et maillottes
on veut que la Polynésie quel que soit
le choix indépendante ou pas elle reste
uni parce que le peuple Maori il est uni
marorou merci beaucoup monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Johnny
aard pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mesame et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
dans un contexte de vie cher exacerbé en
areem après un éem 493 vous avez fait le
choix unilatéral de ne pas retenir parmi
les mesures adoptées par l'Assemblée sur
le budget 2024 mon amendement repris par
la commission des finances de 500
millions d'euros sur la continuité
territoriale outre M visant à faire
baisser les prix des billets d'avion
vous avez par contre choisi de retenir
la mesure 55 non débattu dans laquelle
l'État incite je cite les personnes
résidants en France métropolitaine à
s'installer dans ces territoire d'outrem
grâce à l'argent public d'autre part le
modèle de transport public Corse avec
l'Hexagone pour les passagers et les
marchandises est un modèle d'égalité et
d'équité quand les insulaires des
outremèes sont captifs du seul moyen de
mobilité extérieure que représente
l'avion et condamné à utiliser un
transport privé à des tarifs
insupportables vous refusez ainsi au dit
ultramarin l'égalité des droits inscrit
dans la Constitution et le droit
légitime à la mobilité durable à
l'intérieur de la République França
enfin les autremè contributeurs
importants à la puissance française dans
le monde sont autage d'un modèle
économique caractérisé par le
développement de monopole et d'oligopole
ce système économique historique
consolide des concentrations verticales
et horizontales sans précédent dans un
silence assourdissant de l'État il
produit également un mal développement
qui se traduit notamment par d'extrême
dépendan des inégalités des injustice
profonde et des crises socio-économiques
récurrentes les conséquences sont graves
car elles génèent une colère collec un
fort rejet de l'État jusqu'à nourrir la
violence le risque de chaos et
l'avènement d'une nouvelle crise majeure
tout en faisant le lit des extrémismes
face à ces ruptures d'égalité profonde à
la dégradation continue d' niveau de vie
porteuse d'un désastre annoncé
acceptez-vous de revoir votre position
confirmez-vous devant la représentation
nationale l'engagement de retrait de
l'article 55 pris ce matin par le
Ministre d'Anin acceptez-vous d'ouvrir
une concertation avec les parlementaires
et les collectivités locales d'outrem
pour prendre en compte nos réalités de
vie êtes-vous prêt entre autres à faire
a voté la loi qui garantit aux outres
mèes le même modèle de continuité
territoriale que celui accordé à la
Corse dans le respect de la dignité
humaine il s'agit d'ouvrir des
perspectives de progrès et de donner des
réponses à la hauteur des
enè merci la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe bigier ministre en charge des
outrem merci madame la Présidente Madam
monessieurs les députés monsieurs les
députés har je connais votre
attachachement on a l'occasion d'en
parler à plusieurs reprises du sujet de
la continuité territoriale pour tous les
Parlement qui sont là c'est comment on
aide
financièrement en payant une grande
partie des billets d'avion à faire en
sorte que celles et ceux qui sont dans
l'Hexagone puissent rentrer dans les
meilleures conditions dans des
territoires
ultramarins je vous rappelle que pour le
budget
2024 cette aide à la continuité
territoriale passe de 70 millions à 93
millions d'euros alors vous auriez voulu
j'entends votre message que on puisse
aller encore plus loin et l'augmenter de
60 millions d'euros regarde le
rapporteur général du budget et tous les
parlementaires qui sont là je crois que
c'est une aide majeure que nous faisons
pour 2024 mais une aide importante et
indispensable il faut dire aussi
monsieur le député vous le savez très
bien que les étudiants de première année
qu'il soi boursiux ou qu'il ne le soit
pas auront dès Noël dans un mois la
possibilité de bénéficier de cette
continuité territoriale il faut dire
aussi que nous avons relevé le cur
familial de 12000 à 12000 € ça veut dire
que 77 % je dis bien 77 % des
ultramarins pourront bénéficier de ce
dispositif et nous le faisons dans un
contexte financier la première ministre
a bien voulu que dans le casadre du 493
il y ait des possibilités nouvelles
offertes aux outremes nous renforçons
significativement ce qu'on appelle le
FEI le fond exceptionnel
d'investissement qui de 110 millions
passera à 160 millions d'euros et nous
renforçons l'expertise pour aider les
collectivités de 10 à 20 millions
d'euros donc vous voyez nous sommes au
rendez-vous pour les outr maires nous
continuerons de travailler ensemble pour
égir encore cette offre nous le ferons
je vous le dis et pour comparer avec la
Corse je vous dirais juste une chose si
vous tenez compte uniquement de la
territorial il faut aussi tenir compte
des des fiscalisations qui existent et
là elles sont nombreuses et si on fait
un équilibre total vous verrez que les
ultremères ne sont pas oublié je vous
enfz la démonstration quand vous le
voudrez monsieur le député merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à madame la Présidente Parmentier
leco pour le groupe Renaissance merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la première ministre
madame la Première ministre en 2040 près
d'un Français sur 3 sera âgé de plus de
60 ans d'ici une dizaine d'années une
forte progression du nombre de personnes
âgées de 75 ans et plus est attendue et
face au vieillissement de la population
et à la perte d'autonomie qui préoccupe
fortement nos
concitoyens le gouvernement notre
majorité et tous les bands de cette
assemblée sont
mobilisés en 2020 nous avons créé la 5è
branche de la sécurité sociale dédiée à
l'autonomie dans le projet de voie de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 les recettes de la CNSA sont en
augmentation de 2 milliards et demi et
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie prévoit 15 milliards
d'euros pour les personnes âgées le
projet doit de finance prévoit également
la création de place et de recrutement
professionnel dans les épad
d'investissement dans les épad et dans
les résidences autonomies jamais aucune
majorité n'aura mis autant de moyens sur
l'autonomie c'est vrai cette semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale nous examinons la
proposition de loi pour bâtir la société
du Bien Vieillir qui apporte une
nouvelle brique pour améliorer le
quotidien des personnes âgées et des
professionnels cependant même la
première ministre pour répondre aux
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens il nous
faut aller plus loin et vous avez
annoncé hier votre volonté de mettre en
œuvre une loi de programmation en
2024 madame la Première ministre vous
savez l'attente et l'espoir que suscite
cette annonce aussi pouvez-vous nous
confirmer ici votre engagement pour
l'année 2024 et détailler votre
stratégie interministérielle je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma chè collègue
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Charlotte parmontier Lecoq
la question du Bien Vieillir nous
concerne collectivement et elle doit
nous rassembler c'est un sujet qui
touche chacun d'entre nous pour ses
grands-parents pour ses parents pour
soi-même pour tous ceux qui ont besoin
d'aide dans leur vie de tous les jours
pour les nombreuses familles qui ont un
parent en épad c'est un enjeu dès
aujourd'hui et cela sera encore plus
demain car avec l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie la question de
l'autonomie et du grand âge sera l'un
des défis majeurs de notre
société depuis 2017 et vous l'avez
rappelé madame la Présidente beaucoup a
été fait en pleine crise sanitaire nous
avons notamment créé la 5è branche de la
sécurité sociale la branche autonomie
c'était une réforme attendue depuis de
longues années nous lui avons donné des
moyens inédits que nous augmenterons de
10 milliards d'euros sur le quinquena
avec la proposition de lois sur le Bien
Vieillir que vous examinez actuellement
nous nous allons franchir une nouvelle
étape concrètement ce sont des avancées
importantes pour la prévention de la
perte d'autonomie pour lutter contre les
maltraitances pour un service public
départemental de l'autonomie ou encore
pour une meilleure reconnaissance des
aides à domicile et je tiens à saluer
madame la Présidente votre travail ainsi
que celui des deux rapporteurs du texte
Annie Vidal et Laurence
Christol et je veux remercier les
groupes de la majorité comme des
oppositions qui contribuent à enrichir
le texte mais face au défi démographique
devant nous nous devons aller encore
plus loin nous devons répondre à quatre
grandes questions quels sont nos besoins
comment les financer comment disposer
des compétences et des personnels
nécessaires comment améliorer la
gouvernance sur ce sujet majeur de
nombreux parlementaires ont ont porté
l'idée d'une loi de programmation sur le
grand antage comme je l'ai annoncé hier
en marge de mon déplacement à Strasbourg
cette loi de programmation nous la
ferons j'ai demandé à la ministre des
Solidarités Aurore berger d'engager des
concertations avec les parlementaires de
tous les groupes avec les conseils
départementaux et avec les
professionnels du secteur nous voulons
nous doter ensemble d'une vision
partagée des besoins des financements et
des responsabilités nous avancerons dans
l'esprit constructif et transpartisant
qui a prévalu jusqu'à présent sur ce
sujet et je suis je souhaite qu'un texte
puisse être présenté d'ici l'été pour un
examen et une adoption au second
semestre
mesdames et messieurs les députés
l'autonomie et le grand âge sont des
enjeux centraux pour l'avenir de notre
société cette loi de programmation nous
permettra d'y répondre ensemble je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre la parole est à Madame Pascale
Martin pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre en charge du
logement dans 3 jours aura lieu la
Journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la violence à l'égard
des femmes je voudrais commencer par
rappeler que cette date a été choisie en
commémoration d'un assassinat politique
celui des trois sœurs Mirabal patria
Minerva et Maria Teresa tué le 25
novembre 1960 en République Dominicaine
en raison de leur combat contre la
dictature 63 ans plus tard la violence
politique continue de s'abattre sur les
femmes qui osent résister à l'oppression
comme c'est le cas en Iran à ces
violences politiques et aux guerres dont
les premières victimes sont souvent les
femmes viennent s'ajouter les violences
sexistes ordinaires ces violences là les
femmes de France n'y échappent pas
l'accès à l'hébergement d'urgence pour
les femmes victimes de violence devient
critique depuis cet été beaucoup d'entre
elles sont laissées sans aucune solution
d'hébergement le manque structurel de
place est aggravé par des consignes
préfectorales qui impose au 115 un tri
drastique monsieur le ministre vous
comprenez que ces femmes sont en danger
si on les force à cohabiter avec leur
agresseur vous le comprenez à côté de ça
un nombre croissant de femmes enceintes
ou de mèr avec des jeunes enfants
parfois des bébés se retrouve à la rue
la majorité d'entre elles sont des
femmes étrangères qui ont subi des
violences graves sur leur parcours
migratoire leur grossesse est souvent la
conséquence d'un viol en restant à la
rue elles sont à très haut risque de
subir de nouvelles violence et je ne
parle pas des risques pour leurs enfants
heureusement les parlementaires sont
mobilisés avec les associations
féministes mais le problème ne pourra
être résolu que si l'État joue
correctement son rôle monsieur le
ministre quand le gouvernement va-t-il
s'attaquer réellement au problème quand
allez-vous le faire inutile de prétendre
faire de la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes une priorité des
public des politique publique inutile de
vouloir réduire le nombre de féminicides
si la mise à l'abri des f n'est pas
assuré merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame berangerre Couillard ministre en
charge de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et de la lutte contre les
discriminations merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Martin vous
abordez plusieurs sujets dans votre dans
votre question vous avez commencé par
parler de la journée consacrée à la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et notamment vous interpellez le
gouvernement sur le travail que nous
menons depuis mainten maintenant 2017
vous dire bien sûr que c'est une
priorité et que nous agissons
particulièrement pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes et
particulièrement sur les violences
conjugales vous savez nous avons
travaillé notamment à la mise en place
d'un certain nombre de dispositifs vous
citez l'hébergement d'urgence nous avons
doublé le nombre de places d'hébergement
d'urgence depuis 2017 lorsque nous
sommes arrivés en responsabilité il y en
avait 5000 seulement nous sommes à plus
de 10000 disponies donc pour les femmes
victimes de violence conjugale
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il y a une demande
faite au 115 les femmes victimes de
violence conjugale les femmes victimes
du système prostitutionnel sont
prioritaires dans les attributions de
ces logements il y a le sujet de la
quantité de logement il y a aussi le
sujet de la qualité des logements et moi
je vais demander en début d'année
prochaine un l'état des lieux sur ce qui
est justement l'état de nos logements
pour savoir si nos les femmes et les
enfants sont hébergés dans des
conditions dignes c'est un travail que
nous avons déjà engagé avec le ministre
du Logement et je tiens à vous rassurer
sur cette question vous savez en moyenne
une femme il lu faut en moyenne SEP
allers-retours avant qu'elle puisse
partir définitivement du domicile il y a
bien sûr l'emprise effectuée par le mari
violent ou le conjoint violent mais
aussi ce sont des contraintes
administratives des contraintes
financières qui sont exercées et c'est
pourquoi nous lançons le pack nouveau
départ cette année dans C départements
et nous déployons également l'aide
universelle d'urgence une aide de 243 €
à plus de 1500 € en fonction des
conditions évidemment de cette personne
pour pouvoir l'aider au départ merci
beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas tiré pour le groupe
écologiste madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé lundi a
été publiée une étude de la l'agence
régionale de santé Île-de-France elle
révèle une contamination généralisée des
œufs et des sols à plusieurs polluants
organiques persistants 40 communes de
l'agglomération parisienne sont
concernées en samarne dans les ivelines
dans lesones dans le valdoise les taux
de polluant sont jusqu'à 10 fois
supérieur au seuil de dangerosité pas
moins de 90 % des œufs analysés sont non
conformes aux valeurs seuil pour rappel
l'exposition à ces polluant organique
persistant y compris au cours du
développement fétal peuvent avoir de
nombreux effets sur la santé à long
terme augmentation des risques de cancer
trouble de la fertilité perturbation du
système endocrinien ou trouble du
métabolisme cette alerte en région
parisienne est la dernière d'une liste
qui s'allonge et concerne une part
croissante de nos
territoires il y a quelques mois la
préfecture de la Haute Savoie
interdisait la consommation des poissons
pêchés à proximité de la commune de
remille en raison de la contamination à
une famille de polluant organique
persistant l'épiface peu avant la
préfecture du Ron appelait elle aussi à
ne pas consommer les ufs pendus dans la
région lyonnaise pour les mêmes raisons
les conclusions de ces études sont
convergentes la contamination des sols
et des aliments par les polluants
organiques persistants semble généralisé
cette succession de scandales sanitaires
qui tombe comptegoutte SEM le doute
comment ne pas y voir une préoccupation
de santé publique majeure qui concerne
l'ensemble du territoire la
représentation nationale de même que nos
concitoyens doivent disposer d'une
information suffisante claire et
transparente sur les risques sanitaires
qui pèseent potentiellement sur eux ma
question est donc la suivante monsieur
le ministre pouvez-vous vous engager a
diligenté des études similaires à celles
menées en île-de-fance dans tous les
grands bassins de vie du territoire
national merci pour votre réponse je
vous remerci la parole est à Madame
Agnès firmain lebudau ministre en charge
de l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Nicolas tiri
tout d'abord je vous sais très mobilisé
sur ce sujet essentiel et salue
l'amendement que vous avez porté en PLF
pour augmenter de 10 millions d'euros le
budget alloué à la prévention des
risques liés au pfas mieux prendre en
compte les effets liés au poloin éternel
ou pfas constitue une urgence
environnementale et sanitaire et la
liste des exemples que vousenez de CIT
en est la preuve sur laquelle le
gouvernement est en interministérielle
pleinement mobilisé d'abord dans l'objet
de la surveillance dans le contrôle
sanitaire de la qualité des eaux
réalisées par les ARS sur la base des
recommandations de l'ANS mais aussi nous
avons renforcé cette surveillance en
allant au-devant des directives
européennes qui doivent s'appliquer en
2026 en allongeant la liste des
nouvelles
pface qui sont contrôlés en nouvelle
Aquitaine lairs a lancé dans le cadre de
son Plan Régional de Santé Environnement
une étude pilotée qui permet d'aller
au-delà sur la le contrôle de l'eau
potable en curatif pour éliminer ce qui
est déjà là avec la mise en place du
plan d'action 2023 2027 sur l'épéface
avec un travail en cours de
cartorographie des rejets sur l'ensemble
du territoire et une démarche de
réduction des des rejets bien sûr les
résultats vous seront communiqués depuis
l'arrêté de juin 2023 les industriels
relevant de certaines activités on ont
l'obligation de réaliser sous 3 mois une
campagne de mesure de leur rejet dans
l'eau enfin au préventif avec la mise en
œuvre en interministériel du plan haut
qui prévoit notamment de renforcer la
protection des captages et par la mise
en œuvre de la nouvelle stratégie
écofito sur les sur les enjeux des de la
santé des enfants en lien avec la
prévention c'est un sujet essentiel de
biosurveillance et c'est toute l'objet
des études que nous n menons avec santé
publique France des parlementaires dans
le cadre du GSE piloté par Anne Cécile
VIOLAND une mission interministère
confié sous l'autorité de la première
ministre à cab CIB sont en cours je vous
propose de vous associer à ces travaux
si vous le souhaitez je vous remercie je
vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas excusez-moi allezy merci madame
la ministre vous n'avez néanmoins pas
répondu à ma question ma question était
simple est-ce que vous allez généraliser
le même type d'étude mené en Île de
France dans tous les bassins de VI de
notre pays c'était ça ma
question merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas turcois pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre madame la
Première ministre je pense qu'en ce
moment nombre de nos compatriotes se
sentent autant israélien que palestinien
et nous sommes collectivement meurtris
de la situation au Proche Orient le
Hamas et ses atrocité du 7 octobre ont
plongé ces deux peuples dans un abîme
sans fond il devra en payer le prix le
peuple palestinien n'est pas le Hamas il
est la victime collatérale de cette
organisation
terroriste mais aujourd'hui ce sont des
centaines de milliers de femmes d'hommes
et surtout d'enfants qui sont privés de
toit d'électricité de nourriture d'eau
de soins et qui n'ont aucune possibilité
de
s'enfuir les accords de cette nuit
constituent le premier pas depuis 46
jours vers une acalmie du conflit en
échange d'une libération encore trop
partielle de 50 aage par le Hamas l'État
d'Israël accepterait de de cesser pour 5
jours ses opérations cette accord doit
aussi et c'est un point important
permettre d'intensifier l'aide
humanitaire aux civils
palestiniens madame la Première ministre
pouvez-vous d'abord nous faire un point
sur la question des
otages peut-on considérer que cet accord
pourrait être un premier acte sur la
voie du cesser le feu d'autre part
comment la France peut-elle agir pour
venir en aide aux populations civil en
danger et avec quels moyen opérationnel
enfin quelle action diplomatique
d'envergure peuvent être mené le conflit
israélo-palestinien n'a que trop duré
comme l'a très bien dit mon collègue
bourlange président bourlange l'autre
jour il nous faut affirmer encore plus
haut et encore plus fort la nécessité
d'une solution à deux états où chacun
devra reconnaître les besoins légitimes
de l'autre je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Madame chou zacaropouou secrétaire
d'État en charge du développement de la
Francophonie et des partenariats
internationaux madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
messieur les députés
nicolasriss les attaque terroriste
diam nous avons fait une priorité la
libération des otages aujourd'hui c'est
un jour d'espoir car un accord comme
vous avez dit a été trouvé hier pour la
libération de
sa50age la France est pleinement
mobilisée pour ces libération le
président de la République la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
et les ministres des armées se sont
rendus dans la région pour réaliser cet
objectif et je souhaite ici remercier
tous les États qui ont participé à
l'élaboration de cet accord le Qatar
l'Israël bien sûr l'Égypte et les
États-Unis pour envenir aussi à votre
question sur l'aide humanitaire de la
France à Gaza vous avez vous savez que
nous avons considérablement renforcé
notre aide et que nous mobilisons tous
les moyens possibles pour soutenir la
population de gaz au total la France a
cheminé plus de 110 tonnes d'aide
humanitaire vers l'Égypte et la France
contribue à l'aide humanitaire
européenne par deux vols prochaines le
23 et le 30 novembre sous l'aide
médicale spécifiquement notre aide
permettra de soigner jusqu'à 1000
blessés graves nous avons envoyé deux
postes sanitaires mobiles nous avons
engager les portes hélicoptères d'xmoud
qui se rendent en Égypte et nos
établissement ici hospitaliers sont
prêts à accueillir jusqu'à 50 patientes
en provenance de Gaza en en particulier
les enfants blessés ou malades qu'ils
ont besoin de soins urgents la trêve
humanitaire qui commence permettra
d'avancer sur ses actions et d'aller les
souffrances des population civiles à
Gaza nous continuons par ailleurs à évr
enesser le fait comme l'a demandé le
président de la République voilà pour
conclure ce pilier merci beaucoup madame
la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur max
maazin pour le groupe merci merci Madame
la
présidentees chersèges monsieur le
ministre associe à ma question
l'ensemble des députés ultramarins et
également ceux de nos collègues qui ont
compris le sens de notre combat pour le
retrait de l'article 55 du budget
article qui a soulevé je veux dire la
colère dans nos territoires les députés
ultramarins mobilisés contre cet article
ont été reçus ce matin à leur demande
par Monsieur Gérald daranet ministre de
l'Intérieur et des autres maires nous
lui avons
expliqué les les effets est pervers de
cet article qui prévoit une aide à
l'installation professionnelle pour tous
les actifs quel que soit leur
origine territoire ultramarin ou pas
nous lui avons rappelé que c'est le
gouvernement et lui seul qui qui a
maintenu qui lui ce qui avait maintenu
cet article en dépit de notre opposition
unanime nous lui avons demandé le
retrait de cet article et il l'a fait il
nous a entendu nous lui nous l' Remer
nous lui en remercions
il s'agit pour nous de reprendre les les
mesures proposées dans l'article initial
dans la proposition de la proposition de
loi 1159 dont je suis co-auteur avec mon
collègue Olivier serva notre demande est
clairement un passeport pour le retour
au pays il s'agit maintenant d'envisager
une réécriture pour que seul soit
éligible nos concitoyens vivants dans
l'Hexagone pouvant justifier du centre
de Le s intérêts matériels et moraux
c'est-à-dire CIMM dans un territoire
ultult
ultrarin si une telle réécr n'était pas
possible nous demanderons le maintien du
retrait monsieur le ministre comment
envisagez-vous tenir compte de ce que je
viens de vous dire dans le cadre de la
navette parlementaire pour pour tenir
compte de des exigences de nos
populations merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Vigier ministre en charge des
outr m merci madame la Présidente
madamees Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député max
matiasin vous posez une question
importante c'est celle du déclin
démographique que l'on constate par
exemple en en Martinique en Guadeloupe
et qui avait été constaté par chacun je
rappelle juste un chiffre un jeune sur
de entre 2011 et 2021 est parti mais
n'est pas revenu dans son pays d'origine
en Martinique ou en guadeloup face à
cela il y a un article de la loi de
finance s'appelle le fameux article 55
ce quel article 55 prévoit quoi il
prévoit des aides à l'incitation pour
faire en sorte que l'on puisse organiser
le retour naturellement vers ces
territoirees ultramarin cet article dis
est sans détour et pas compris il n'est
pas accepté et il suscite beaucoup
d'émotion ce matin et à l'initiative de
la première ministre avec Gérald derman
1 nous avons reçu vous le savez vous
étiez présent l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui nous ont érogés sur
cette question d'ors et déjà je suis en
mesure de vous dire que nous allons
retirer l'article 55 et nous avons
convenu ensemble je le dis devant la
représentation nationale et devant le
président de la délégation qui est là
David riman qu'une proposition de
rédaction commune sera faite dans le
casre d'une coconstruction entre les
parlementaire et entre le gouvernement
de manière à vous apporter satisfaction
et on tiendra compte de quelque chose
qui a été porté par le député serva dans
sa proposition de loi tenir compte
notamment ce qu'on appelle du CIMM des
centres d'intérêt d'intérêt par pardon
matériels et moraux de manière à ce que
l'on puisse donner une priorisation aux
ultramarins pour qu'ils puissent
retourner au pays et dernier mot puisque
nous terminons la loi de finances je
vous rappelle je vous rappelle que dans
le casadre du budget c'est 2 millions
d'euros en plus pourpositive cadre
d'avenir qui permettra justement à des
jeunes formés dans l'Hexagone de
retourner exercer toutes leurs
compétences dans les territoires
ultraarin voilà Monsieur le
Député merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Vincent Rolland
pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre après les
haut de France des crus torrentiels ont
frappé le département de la Savoie dans
la nuit du 14 au 15 novembre dernier par
chance aucune victime n'est à déplorer
permettez-moi de remercier l'ensemble
des élus locaux des pompiers gendarmes
association de sécurité civile agents
des collectivités et bien sûr sur tous
les bénévoles qui ont prêté main forte
au sinistrés de nombreuses nombreuses
habitations et infrastructures sont
néanmoins endommagés au niveau de
Notre-Dame de briillançon commune de
l'aléchère la ligne SNCF entre
Alberville et bourg sa-maaurice est
coupé comme dans la voilée voisine de la
Morienne une liaison rompue qui a
évidemment un impact immédiat sur les
usagers du quotidien et et qui sucite
de vives inquiétudes en ce qui concerne
la saison hivernale à venir avec 400000
lit touristique dont une partie est
desservie par le train ce sont tous les
professionnels de l'économie de la
montagne qui s'inquiètent à l'approche
de la saison je pense également à
l'entreprise
MSSA dont l'usage de la ligne est
indispensable pour permettre un
transport sécurisé du chlore vous
l'aurez compris l'accessibilité
ferroviaire est essentielle pour ce
territoire tant pour les usagers que
pour le tourisme et
l'industrie aussi madame la Première
ministre pouvez-vous prendre
l'engagement que l'état de catastrophe
naturelle sera pris dans les plus brefs
délais pour les nombreuses familles qui
sont dans le désarrois par ailleurs
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui nous annoncer
une date de réouverture de cette ligne
SNCF dont les enjeux économiques sont
considérables je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre en
charge de la transition écologique et de
la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Roland vous l'avez
dit dans la nuit du 14 au 15 novembre
une crue historique dans la vallée de
larve a battu le record du 1er mai 2015
et est les plus importantes enregistré
depuis qu'on mesure ses cru depuis 1904
on a atteint jusqu'à 1000 m³ par seconde
avec quelque chose qui est directement
relié au dérèglement climatique parce
qu'on a à la fois l'intensité
extrêmement forte des inondations mais
on a dans le même temps le fait que de
l'eau qui aurait pu tomber sous forme de
neige à cause de la douceur des
températures est venu s'ajouter à des
précipitations et à augmenter les dégâts
dans cette vallée vous avez cité les
lignes ferroviaires je voudrais associer
si vous voulez bien les maréchés de
Gaillard et les usines plus larges de
maglan et dire au passage que au milieu
de tout ça je veux
prolonger je prolonger ce que vous venez
de dire saluer les investissements qui
ont été conduits les
programmes notamment les papis qui ont
été conduits en 2012 et en 2020 saluer
les investissements qui ont été faits
par les collectivités locales vous
m'interrogez sur la reconnaissance de
catastroph naturell compte tenu de
l'ampleur de cette
crue dans les prochains jours puisque
vous savez que c'est le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui à la fois examine les
dossiers et qui entraîne cette
reconnaissance va examiner la situation
de ces territoires vu ce que je viens de
dire en parlant de cru d'ampleur
historique vous avez une petite idée de
la manière dont la commission sera
amenée à statuer de façon encore plus
concrète les maires concernés puisque
nous passons par les mairies doit faire
remonter leur dossier dans les plus
brefs délais pour que cette Commission
puisse se tenir à beauovau et nous
sommes en train de consolider les
hypothèses de réouverture de ces lignes
ferroviaires parce que nous avons bien
conscience que le cas cendrier lié à la
saison touristique qui commence amène
une pression encore plus forte que si
les mêmes difficultés avaient eu lieu à
un autre moment je peux vous assurer de
mon attention et celle du ministre de
l'Intérieur sur le sujet merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre allez-y mon cher
collègue simplement monsieur le ministre
je vous parlais de la vallée de la
Tarantaise en Savoie et de la vallée en
Morienne et pas de la vallée de l'Arve
en haut saie merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
Monsieur le président marcangéi pour le
groupe
horizon merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre le lundi 20
novembre se tenait la journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant
au-delà de cette date symbolique je sais
qu'un large consensus existe sur ces
bans pour protéger les plus jeunes des
dangers susceptibles d'entraver le
chemin de leur épanouissement preuve en
a été faite par l'adoption à l'unanimité
ici même ainsi qu'au Sénat de la
proposition de loi visant à instaurer
une majorité numérique et à lutter
contre la haine en ligne le mercredi 28
juin 2023 cette proposition de loi je
l'ai porté avec humilité en ayant
conscience qu'elle ne pourrait pas tout
résoudre son objectif est simple
permettre aux parents de mieux
superviser la vie en ligne de leurs
enfants alors que les utilisateurs de
réseaux sociaux sont de plus en plus
jeunes et que des études scientifiques
pointent les risques d'une exposition
intensive à âge précoce chaque jour les
réseaux sociaux sont submergés par des
contenus de plus en plus violents erroné
et indécent c'est une véritable course
contre la montre pour préserver la santé
mentale de nos enfants qui est engagé je
prendrai l'exemple de la dernière
émission de téléréalité qui énonde les
réseaux sociaux French Shore à la limite
de la pornographie elle verse dans le
trash et la vulgarité permanente combien
de collégiens combien d'écoliers sont
ainsi exposés à tout ou parti de cette
émission madame la Première ministre je
connais votre engagement sur cette
question comme en témoigne l'avis
favorable que vous avez donné sur cette
proposition de loi malgré la
promulgation de cette dernière le 7
juillet dernier par le Président de la
République son application reste
aujourd'hui suspendue à une appréciation
de la Commission européenne pourtant le
temps presse pouvez-vous indiquer à la
représentation nationale quelle est la
position du Gouvernement sur ce sujet je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président Laurent
marcangelli vous avez raison de le dire
la protection des mineurs dans l'espace
numérique est un enjeu majeur et je veux
saluer monsieur le président marangéi le
travail remarquable que vous avez mené
grâce notamment à la loi instaurant une
majorité numérique une loi qui protège
nos enfants et interdit la création d'un
compte sur un réseau social avant 15 ans
sans autorisation des parents une loi
que le gouvernement a soutenu et qui a
été adoptée à la quasi unanimité dans
cette assemblée comme au Sénat monsieur
le Président marcangelli face au défi de
la régulation numérique vous le savez
c'est avec l'Union européenne que nous
pourrons peser et trouver des solutions
efficaces c'est une conviction qui nous
rassemble c'est un enjeu que nous avons
porté lors de la présidence française du
Conseil de l'Union européenne et nous
avons réussi après 20 ans de tentatives
infructueuses avec le règlement DSA nous
sommes parvenus à imposer au géants du
numérique une régulation européenne
conforme à notre vision et à nos valeurs
nous avons imposer une règle simple tout
ce qui est interdit hors ligne doit
l'être également en ligne le DSA nous
donne les moyens d'agir face aux grands
acteurs du numérique qui ne pourront
plus jouer sur la diversité de nos
normes et avec le ministre Jean-Noël
barreot mon gouvernement a porté devant
le Parlement un projet de loi qui assure
la mise en œuvre de ce règlement mais
qui permet aussi de prendre de nouvelles
mesures notamment pour protéger les
enfants je pense à la protection des
mineur face à la pornographie à la lutte
contre le cyberhcèlement ou à
l'instauration d'une peine de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux
monsieur le Président marcangelli dans
le cadre du droit européen nous pouvons
naturellement agir et légiférer et je
pense en particulier à cette question de
la majorité numérique notre action au
niveau de l'Union européenne et
nationale se complète nous pouvons et
nous devons les coordonner parfaitement
c'est pourquoi nous travaillons en ce
moment même avec la commission
européenne pour articuler votre loi avec
les travaux européens et permettre son
entrée en vigueur dans les meilleurs
délis je vous remercie beaucoup madame
la Première ministre monsieur le
Président merci pour votre réponse
madame la Première ministre qui est très
claire j'insiste véritablement sur sur
cet enjeu ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux est gravissime vous avez
des ingérences étrangères vous avez des
violences inacceptables je crois qu'on
est devant un enjeu de civilisation nous
devons apporter une réponse
particulièrement forte bra merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président la parole
est à Monsieur Grégoire de fournaz pour
le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire ces derniers jours de
nombreux villages de France ont vu leur
panneau retourner par des agriculteurs
manifestant leur colère de votre
écologie punitive imposée par la
stratégie bruxelloise dit de la ferme à
la fourchette elle-même inspirée par la
pire philosophie décroissante de
l'extrême gauche on marche sur la tête
c'est le mot d'ordre que les
agriculteurs proclament dans cette
nouvelle forme de mobilisation en effet
quand vous laissez notre agriculture en
concurrence et déloyale avec la terre
entière et qu'en même temps vous plombez
une nouvelle fois la compétitivité des
exploitations en augmentant les taxes
sur le GNR les produits phytosanitaire
ou sur l'eau on peut le dire on marche
sur la tête alors que les trois lois
égalim et les closes miroir sont un
échec à garantir des prix rémunérateurs
et que chaque jour la situation de nos
agriculteurs s'aggrave des décisions
urgentes doivent être prises mais vous
donnez vous aussi l'impression de gagner
du temps par un par un enfumage
permanent qui je vous le dis masque mal
votre inaction les agriculteurs n'en
peuvent plus des bavardages et de ces
milliers d'heures de concertation pour
préparer une loi d'orientation agricole
main de fois repoussé et qui s'annonce
déjà comme dérisoire face aux grands
enjeux de l'agriculture française
monsieur le ministre les agriculteurs
ont compris qu'ils n'ont plus rien à
attendre de cette majorité pour
redresser notre agriculture mais face à
leur détresse pouvez-vous au moins
aujourd'hui nous annoncer que vous
renoncez à cette augmentation des taxes
sur le GNR sur l'eau et les RPD décision
injuste et insurmontable compte tenu de
la situation dramatique des des
exploitations agricoles
françaises merci beaucoup la parole est
à Monsieur Marc fenau ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le députés de fournass il reste
combien on a le droit évidemment de dire
tout parfois ça confine un peu au
n'importe quoi sur les sujets agricoles
pardon de vous le dire comme ça d'abord
parce qu'on a un cap le cap c'est celui
qu'on a tracé dès 2017 au travers de la
rémunération je ne connais pas un
agriculteur vous leur demanderez
vous-même qui voudrait qu'on revienne
sur les lois qui ont été faites sur
égalim égalim 1 égalim 2 la troisème
faite par le député descroosille et son
groupe et qui personne n'avait
travailler sur cette question de la
rémunération ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas qu'on progresse encore mais je ne
connais pas un agriculteur qui vous
dirait pas que ceux qui sont rentrés
dans égalim n'ont pas pu voir leur
revenus progresser ça veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas de difficultés ça c'est un
cap le cap de la rémunération c'est un
cap important le deuxième cap qu'on a
donné c'est le cap de la souveraineté de
la transition il y a ceux qui comme vous
en tout cas de ce que j'entends disent
qu'il faut rien changer la meilleure
façon de faire disparaître l'agriculture
c'est de ne pas l'adapter et de ne pas
lu permettre de faire face à la grande
transition qui est lié notamment au
dérèglements climatiques les berces de
production et vous le vivez vous-même
dans le vignoble bordelai c'est en
partie lié à la question du dérèglement
climatique donc on a besoin d'adapter
pour ça on a besoin d'objets qui sont
ceux de la planification et c'est
là-dessus qu'on travaille pour de mettre
en cohérence nos objectifs nos moyens et
les objectifs qui sont de nature diverse
troisème élément pour être crédible faut
mettre des moyens pardon vous ne l'avez
pas voté en tout cas vous n apprêtiez
pas à le faire la question des moyens
sur l'agriculture plus 1,3 milliards
d'euros jamais il y a eu des crédits qui
avaient augmenté dans cette mesure là
pour la décarbonation pour
l'accompagnement sur les phyos pour
faire face aux grandes transitions ça
c'est des faits c'est des faits concrets
pardon excusez-moi de vous le dire c'est
des faits concrets puis à ce qu'on fait
aussi sur le plan haut pour essayer
d'accompagner l'agriculture dans sa
résidence donc c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera à mener la transition et par
ailleurs autant vous dire que sur le
pacte et sur la loi la première ministre
aura l'occasion de s'exprimer
prochainement mais nous serons bien au
rendez-vous du dialogue et du travail
que nous avons fait avec les
agriculteurs bravo merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député monsieur le
ministre votre politique d'adaptation
c'est une politique de la décroissance
et de l'écologie punitive je voudrais
d'ailleurs me réjouir de l'échec du
règlement sû ce matin au Parlement
européen grâce au députés du
rassemblement national je vous remercie
monsieur le
ministre c'est toujours les mêmes mots
et toujours aucune solution que vous
proposez nous on a des solutions on
Essie d'y travailler et pardon de vous
dire que y compris au niveau européen
nous faisons en sorte que nous trouvions
des positions d'équilibre c'est en tout
cas ce à quoi je m'attache je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la séance
de question au gouvernement est terminée
la séance est suspendue et reprendra à
15h sur le texte de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi portant
transposition de l'accord national
interprofessionnel relative au partage
de la valeur je vous
remercie